hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
the Monday morning podcast from Monday
September 14 2015 what's going on oh I
um I know what you guys are expecting
they're probably expecting me to talk
[ __ ] about the Patriots winning and the
Steelers crying about the the headsets
or whatever the hell they were crying
about this week why get why does
everybody you know I love about Giants
fans they never [ __ ] about the Patriots
they just beat us all the rest you
[ __ ] sit there crying every week
anyways I'm not going to get into that I
have a very special guest here one of my
favorite all-time comedians of all times
but first I have to read his amazing
intro here Brian Regan everybody is
going to be performing live at Radio
City Music Hall in the first time ever
in the history of Comedy Central Brian
your minds will talk at this point I've
already said yes how many how many
specials would you guess that Comedy
Central has in there Mountain Wow I
probably quite a few but 7 8 million
yeah 7 to 8 million I think is uh
well this one I'm gonna bet on the over
I'm gonna say it's nine million nine
million I like that uh nine million
specials this is the first guy who's
ever had the nerve to tape a stand-up
special live on Comedy Central and he's
going to be doing it see if I kept ember
26 at 9:00 p.m. live from one of the
most legendary venues of all time Radio
City Music Hall I mean I'm looking the
whole press release you got like you
know five stars from Jerry Seinfeld
Chris Rock Dennis Miller Joe Rogan
Patton Oswalt
Marc Maron the who's who and we all love
you Manuel you are
you've been what's it like to have been
a Comics comic for a quarter of a
century I it's a huge huge honor man you
know when uh you know making audiences
laugh is great makes you feel good but
to also you know make the comedian's
feel like you're doing the right thing
that makes you feel even better I know
my fun in this podcast is going to be
torturing you with you
Kampf compliments because I can tell
them I've ever seen you hey what's it
like to be a legend crying I'm not being
a legend like God say yeah I'll go I'll
go right into a bombing story let me
tell you what how about when I bombed
and that wasn't so legendary no man I've
been doing this ship for 23 years I'm
old now I am an old man now I know that
every time when I try to do stand-up out
and silver like I'm not saying the kids
are bad it's just I definitely feel like
wow man I feel like that that generation
gap but you you've been like since I
started for those people like unfamiliar
who've been living under a stand-up
comedy rock like like Brian basically
goes out and for 90 straight minutes it
sounds like a jet is landing how hard
this guy kills and he never you and
unlike me you couldn't be the more polar
opposite of me
you don't you I don't you think you say
heck no sure I do you say that well yeah
okay but still and I do some hacks and
some dams but to Julie act is like
airtight like nobody can Matt no one
could be like oh you know he's just he's
just what he's just writing perfect
jokes but I'm sorry Brian I hate to
torture with this but there's no other
way to go with this yeah I'm an absolute
master your very kind very incredibly
kind and I cannot thank you enough this
Ricky no eye contact very no like I'm
going to keep going in I remember when I
when I first started headlining in the
late 90s the legend back then was when
you booked Brian Regan you would do two
shows in one night and you would do two
completely our plus totally clean
absolutely destroying sets like you had
like the a set in the be set and you had
like those always this this urban myth
he's got two notebooks they're both
filled up once one super show and once
the second show he's doing me literally
the guy's got two hours and 40 minutes
of a level material I I called it the
idiot and the oddity oh those were the
the two shows there were two different
one-hour shows and I would go to a
comedy club for like a month and and I
would alternate them and the idea was if
somebody came out and they liked what
they saw they go wow he's got another
one maybe we'll come back and see the
other show as well so now did that come
about because back then when you were
coming up like you had to be like
anointed to do a special when nowadays
you just need somebody with the camera
and you can put it up however you wanted
like back in the day HBO had to say like
you know what you're one of the six
people that were picking this year or I
don't even think Comedy Central is
really making too many specials back
then so I was just wondering did you
like you wrote a special at that point
did you just say to hell with I'll just
keep writing like how did you end up
with that much material at one time
actually well be just because I you know
I'm I'm always trying to write stuff but
it came about because do you remember
when people were starting to do the
one-man shows oh yeah like Rob Becker
defending the caveman you know they
would take a stand up and then kind of
make it into a little story with a
beginning middle and an end and they got
a few laughs you sit down behind a desk
yeah I mean Rob Becker's is great in but
there were a lot that were just either
seemed like kind of repackaged stand-up
you know and people were telling me well
you should do a one-man show you should
do a one-man show and I'm like I like
stand-up I like the way stand-up works I
don't want to I don't want to like you
know do a joke and then have a serious
point and then walk across the stage and
doesn't have a tear come out of a
dramatic lighting it you look so funny I
just totally relate to that because I've
had so many people were like my dream
was always I just want if I could sell
out improv that was the dream if I could
if I could just go like I took me when I
was starting out when somebody said oh I
have a gig in Houston this week or I'm
in Minneapolis this week like to me
there was nothing cooler than that like
this guy gets to get on a plane yeah and
fly and people know who he is and he
gets to go in there and back down once
you get to where the sport coat right
you get to go out and be and be a
comedian I just thought the
that was the coolest thing ever and I
don't know how you feel about this one
whenever um you could have like the
greatest special ever and then they're
always just like see any TV any move
like first it's it's always looked at uh
it's got this weird thing or stand-up is
really respected by people but then it's
also looked at as just like this
stepping stone right into uh you know
doing like a uh I don't like a sitcom or
being some sort of actor or something
like that and I always just I always
thought like no dude this is the thing
this is the thing it always will be the
thing I can't get fired from this I'm
always going to be employed and it
happens in real time there's no cut
let's go back and do it again and you
sit in a trailer for 14 hours yeah it's
you know there are you know a few people
who like it as an end result I don't say
a few there are a lot of people who love
stand-up comedy but yes for a lot of
people it's a stepping stone to get into
acting to get into a TV show or movies
and that's great but I like it as it is
you know and um you know people do
always ask about the thing you don't
have you know yeah I just remember for
years you know people coming up to me uh
you know have you ever done The Tonight
Show or whatever and when I hadn't and
yeah like now now I haven't done that
you know you should call Jay yeah that's
nice yeah ya know the very the first
year I was working at the comic strip in
Fort Lauderdale that I was a I work in
the kitchen you know I would like cook
burgers they would let me go on stage at
the end of the night and a guy came up
to me after a show and said um Rodney
Dangerfield is playing down the road at
the sunrise musical theater he goes why
don't you go down there and open for him
instead of this you know like like like
all it took as me to just know where the
theater was like I just walked down
there Oh is he in town ed oh where was
it that way should I just go down there
and I open for him in a theater you just
show with the apron you're mostly a
friend you're such a [ __ ]
in here in a comedy club I could go
right down the road and open for Rodney
Dangerfield do you for the suggestion
but you know what's funny in a way that
mentality is how I got into this
business was because I wanted to be a
comedian I didn't dare say it out loud
but I I didn't think it was possible
because like when I was thinking about
doing it was which is like the lady he
started in the early nineties but the
ladies I first started thinking about it
but there wasn't any YouTube there was
none of that crap so to me I was live in
Massachusetts show business was 3,000
miles away like it just seemed
impossible and then I was working in a
warehouse with this guy and he was just
going like do one of these nights and he
likes staying up by glad he goes one of
these nights I'm gonna take a shot at
Jack Daniels and I'm just going to go
down to an open mic down the street and
you know and just go up on stage and all
of a sudden I was just like oh wow you
can just do that I thought I had to like
you know get my teeth captain moved off
to LA and get a fake tan like I had no
idea hiding so I always I always had
like a panic attack when I think about
that icon thank God I worked with that
guy and thank God that he said that and
he took it out of seeming like you know
it was like the Milky Way away he like
made it like yeah just go right down the
street he just did they did that guy
ever do it you know I don't know because
we work together such for such a short
time I have no idea that's the only
reason why I don't like telling that
story cuz I'm people like did that guy
end up doing it uh-uh whatever happened
to him he's probably like some
zillionaire banker you know hump shoot
you know sell by a pool loving his wife
and kids and his dog is totally happy
but just to me he didn't do what you did
in life so he must not be happy when I
when I first decided I wanted to be a
stand-up the only comedy clubs were in
Los Angeles and New York I was in
college in Tiffin Ohio and I knew I
wanted to do stand-up this is my fourth
year what year was this 1980 this going
way back right and so I knew I wanted to
do it but comedy had not yet you know
exploded it was only in those two cities
so I was gearing up to having to move to
New York City I'm like I didn't know
what was going on so what I thought I
had to do in 92 you actually had to do
an 80 that's what the yeah
and then I went back down to South
Florida which is where I grew up and I
open up the Miami Herald and there's an
ad and the Miami Herald for grand
opening for the comic strip comedy club
in Fort Lauderdale
it says sister Club of the famous comedy
club in New York City open mic night
Monday night and I'm like damn like like
it could not have been more beautifully
perfect like that's I don't have to move
right I don't have to move to New York
City I can just fill up the car with gas
and go up to Fort Lauderdale and try it
and so it became so much more attainable
when I saw that ad you know and that's
where I started that's amazing I am very
similar thing item I made a New Year's
resolution in 1992 that at some point in
the calendar year of 1992 I was going to
do an open mic that's how like shut down
and shy I was I was so nervous about it
and the second I said that within two
weeks in the school paper
the Emersonian I went to Emerson College
it said Knicks Comedy stop I had a
contest it was an ad find Boston's
funniest college student Wow and the
whole thing was just uh just to pack the
club with a bunch of drunk kids right
drinks watching their friends bomb so I
immediately like I I bought the paper uh
might even been free I think I can't
remember the school paper I think was
free and then I brought it home and I
just immediately called the phone number
before I chickened out I was just like I
remember so many kids from Emerson
signed up that they actually gave us two
nights so I was supposed to go on at the
end of something the last Monday in
February and then they called up they
said they had overflow would you'd want
to do the first Monday in March and I
was like okay like just to put it off
and then I hung up and I felt like I
pussied out and but very like a similar
thing so yeah I mean it's weird how
things will leap out at you I mean that
you know all the at of all the ads in
the world you know for fast food places
and hotels and
that ad for that comedy club like jumped
off the page
to me it was like holy [ __ ] man
it was just it was just perfect and then
I went there so it's 1980 so you went
down there so tell me about your first
when you went on stage well actually
they want they wanted you to get there
early to draw numbers so I had to make
the hour drive I was still living with
my parents in Miami I make the hour
drive up there and I get there I don't
know six and did they know you were
gonna try it you pat on oh if I may have
told my parents but I I didn't tell
anybody why didn't I don't tell nobody
nothing you know what I mean that's like
a mob hit yeah it's like no I want to go
up there and if I bomb nobody's gonna
know about this till the day I die slain
you seem so quiet well yeah well nothing
you know what are you doing this year
I'm just getting dressed up and leaving
the house so I go up there and they were
like 20 comedians that I had to draw
numbers you had draw numbers for your
timeslot not I didn't know what any of
this meant and I drew I guess a good
number you know I had like a sweet spot
right in the middle and then right after
the drawing all these other open mike
rizzo have done it before I guess it had
been open like a month you know came up
and said I'll trade you I'll trade you
I'll trade you my number for your number
and all I knew is whatever I was holding
was valuable and I wasn't trading it for
nothing nice you know I'm like they want
this so I'm keeping it so I went on and
what they had three Co headliners it was
very weird and then they stuck the open
mike rizzo pin the middle I went on
right in the middle of the show and I
just completely blanked out on stage
just complete wipeout blank could not
remember anything and did you realize
that walking towards the stage when you
got up and turned and faced them what
happened was I had every word memorized
I had hi how are you written down
which hand you in a wave where
everything a I had hi how are you
written down and memorized I walk on
stage and that's the first time I
realize how bright these lights are like
I'm like wigging out that I can't see a
soul and then I I started to say hi how
are you in the microphone and there was
feedback I was too close I went hi huh
how are you you know oh no so I did my
first ad-lib I said well I've already
learned one thing I don't know how to
work a microphone and it got a laugh oh
nice and then my brain just shut off Oh
cuz you didn't you know what because I
had memorized hi how are you - the next
thing and when I had libbed
yeah I don't know where I was supposed
to go after that and so they laughed at
my ad-lib you know I don't know how to
work a microphone they laughed and I'm
standing there going I don't know I
could I blanked out blank blankety-blank
how long before you I stood there for
about um 10 seconds which seemed like
nine years like an eternity and I said
well you're not gonna blue this folks
but I forgot my act and they laughed and
I said no no no I'm serious
and they laughed it was like a Twilight
Zone thing what you learn and honestly
works and I and I started to ad-libbing
about how stupid I was for not being
able to remember my act and went this is
great I you spent all this time and
effort trying to figure out something
and I can't remember nothing you know
just off the top my head and I started
killing and I and I started killing
rolling about how stupid I was we were
able to enjoy killing ru so I enjoyed it
III knew enough to go all I want is
laughs you know what I mean and I'm just
winging it you know talking about what
an idiot I am and how this Drive I made
and all this stuff memorized and I can't
remember a single thing
buhbuh buhbuh and I crushed it will be
at least in my mind over an open mic
dude that's crushing it and then I said
well I can't see myself ever remember in
any of it
so good ight and then I got this big
hand oh how [ __ ] great I walked out
stage and then like the the headliners
one of them came up to me and said that
that was a great routine about how you
pretended to blank out I said I didn't
pretend they said that you really were
winging out and I was like yeah but I
was like in a fog What did he say
you should definitely come back with a
supportive guy I forget who it was but
he was supportive he said it was really
funny and uh you know so what was great
for me is that my next time I went I
remembered my act and just ate it but
hilarious but I had the memory of
knowing how to make people laugh from
the first time that just kept fueling me
to just keep going back and do you think
what happened if you just did your act
and that first thing didn't happen you
completely ate it did you have it you
think you had any to keep coming back I
don't know you know I've talked to other
comedians about this and and I what's
weird to me is that most comedians I
talked to say that their very first time
on stage they did well you know and then
didn't do well the second time or third
time and I wonder how many potentially
good comedians out there it didn't go
well and just said hell with it now
they're working at a Home Depot
yeah is crushing it every day hey guy
I've ever met my life and they just you
know yeah and I truly wonder how many
people just had the bad experience and
go I need this like I need a hole in the
head you know so I know because the
first time first my first two were I did
Nick's the the the talent thing and went
okay and then I did stitches comedy club
and went did okay and those are both
comedy clubs but the first time I did a
room that wasn't a comedy club I told
the stories Dillion times in the podcast
but it was Jack Lynch had this room
Kelly something-or-other it was some bar
and I went up and I and I absolutely
just ate it wired to wire and I said on
the microphone Jack I'm bailing I said
it to the host and all the communities
went ah like they collectively we're
like disappointing to me that I
and I hated myself I remember but I
would say it never dawned on me to quit
maybe it was because I did well those
first two times but I just never I was
just like alright well what can I do to
avoid that right that awful feeling
again but you know it's funny when I
finally started getting a little bit
funny I actually was doing one of your
mannerisms and people kept giving me
[ __ ] go and you're stealing from Brian
looks like I'm two three years in like
no I'm not your little your crouch thing
that you do
I was so influenced by you because I I
had seen you like first of all everybody
was freaking out when you come into play
next comedy stop and everyone's got do
Brian Ricans coming here Brian Regan and
uh and I was like yeah I'd seen him a
couple too I'd seen you a couple times
on TV it's like you got to see this guy
who's like every comic in Boston was
going you got to see this guy and I was
like I'm doing a dick Daugherty's room
it's like I don't give a [ __ ] finishes
set and drive in here and I came in and
I caught your second set I still
remember you wearing this red button
down shirt you went on stage and you you
were killing so hard like you know
people wiping tears away like falling
into the aisle aisles and stuff and it
was just so like you probably the first
big comic like traveling comic you came
in you followed all the Boston heavy
hitters because you know how they used
to love stinking like yeah you know some
legendary headliner with all the local
references in them feature active Ryan
barrier and you went up totally clean
and it was a combination of watching you
murdering and then seeing all the comics
that I respected like turning into like
audience members and they were doing
that laughs like like love and stand-up
and then being like [ __ ] why didn't I
think of that that's when you doing like
the prescription lens uh when she
lynching and all that it was just it was
an amazing thing and I appreciate it I
was so influenced by that that I started
to out acted out I was doing I was doing
like a little bit of when I would go
into a punch line I would like drop down
a little bit and it took me I did that
for about maybe eight months to a year I
was doing that and it took me about
seven years to get that stink off of me
people now he's stealing from Regan he's
still for Regan I was just like - I was
like I was two years in I didn't know
what I was doing
we're going we got a
learn from something we got to watch it
yeah it's just a huge honor and thank
you so I was actually I was doing you a
little bit and and then I fortunately I
had guys like you know Voss and Norton
and Patrice and all of them they teased
me out of it we used to all we used to
all sit there and trash each other going
you know who you're doing and who you're
doing it I used to tell Patrice he was
doing a little bit of Fred Sanford when
he was going like it is I kind of do
like that thing with his face um so
anyways uh well thank you man now yeah I
don't want to let the good words yeah
well look I won't torture any more
compliments but so how did you come up
with the idea to do a special life I
mean that's well you know um you were
saying about Comedy Central does a lot
of specials with comedians and I've done
a couple of with a couple with them in
the past and uh you know I just I just
wanted to do something different you
know you know what I love about it is
the thing I hate the most about doing is
special is afterwards when you have to
watch the footage and edit and look at
yourself and listen to yourself
I've always for the most part throughout
all the specials I've done the few that
I've done is I just whatever show felt
better I just go just take that shell
mmm and Whittle that down to whatever
time they need because I don't want to
sit there and look at both shows then
it's twice I don't I don't want to
[ __ ] deal with any I hate it I
absolutely hate it and I avoided the way
I do like a term paper so back in the
day so I was thinking about how you're
you're not going to have to do that
you're just going to go out you're going
to do it yeah and it's done and then
another thing too is like the only time
comics do a special where they only have
one show is if they don't have any
budget you clearly you know at this
point you can afford to take two four
six shows if you wanted to you're only
getting you're going to do it all in one
what is the game plan you got going into
that as far as like is there is there
any like mindset that you're going into
before that like alright Brian just go
out there have a good time and some
shits to bed you know dress it and keep
plowing for what do
don't it it's weird like I don't want to
overthink it you know what I mean like
on the one hand I just you know I want
it to be a show just like any other show
just happens to be some cameras in there
and some people out there in my world
watching it you know but at the same
time I I want to have a couple of things
going on like I've been talking to my
manager and Psyche all it takes is one
idiot one idiot in the audience that you
know wants to uh you know have this be
his moment you know it's like you can't
watch golf
you can't watch golf without a guy
hitting a tee shot going to Hall yeah
you just go geez are you really that
starved for attention you guys okay are
you gonna go home and listen to yourself
that was me I yelled go in the hole get
no ogen away they said yeah they all say
it to psyche can come up with something
original it's just you know so I have
this little fear not a big one because
my my audiences are pretty damn cool you
know but all it takes is one idiot in
the audience who's like oh wow it's
going to be live I can do something that
you're right right you know I can get
some attention for myself so but then
you know something then if you trash
them then it just it what it would act
what that would actually do is it makes
it like really unique as far as like if
somebody were to do that and then you
were to trash them even if they were to
kick them out like live on the thing I
don't want to talk about this too much
but you have a great crowd anyways to
give anybody any ideas but actually the
way you're looking at that you know what
I was trying to think you know it's not
like whenever I go do a show I just do
the show wire-to-wire and I don't screw
up any jokes you know what I mean it's
just when you're recording it gets in
your head like oh my god right the
documentation of that joke I flubbed
this word and it's just like you don't
care when the cameras aren't there so I
would think that you would just get into
that [ __ ] you know this is just a
documentary my performance of this hour
on this night and this is how it came
out and you just go out there is that we
going to do yeah well it's been a while
since I've recorded an hour the last
thing I did was about five years ago and
that was a CD I get I get antsy man when
I get material I want to
yeah I guess you know a lot of people
get material and they go wow this is
good material one I want to keep doing
it I get to where it's like I don't want
to do it anymore
yes you know I mean it's like wow this
is really good
I'm sick of it you don't I mean yeah so
I want to like to record it so it's
there you know I mean it exists but now
I can move on you know so that's one
thing I'm really looking forward to is
this material that I've been you know
kicking around for the last four or five
years and I look forward to just nailing
it down and then being done with it the
week after that it's probably going to
be more fun for me like just starting to
play around and and and get back into
some different stuff but I'm really
looking forward to it
but as far as the do you have jokes in
Iraq right now that you hate and you're
actually thinking that oh my not you
hate but you're just so sick of telling
me you're like I can't wait to record
this yes so I can just be done with
bumping up to that and I'm and I try to
resist it and fight it and then like as
soon as I start feeling that way I try
not to do that bit for a month or two
you know yeah so that when I redo it it
feels fresh and this is a challenge
because I'm coming up on this special
and I need to have it in my bones yeah
what degree but not so into my bones
where it's like you're a machine up
there you know I mean you don't suck the
funny out of it you know so it's a
tightrope
I always know which ones subconsciously
I don't even realize how much I hate
certain jokes by the end of them is when
I get one once I do this special it's
just naturally the ones you say you
don't even make the choice the ones you
hate you just never do them again and I
always think like wow man I must have
really hated that joke I must have
really been sick of doing that thing but
uh you know it's funny from to me is
it's just like in your normal
progression you know you come up with a
bit you know some new thing and you're
excited about it you you know you have
your hit list rate of uh here's
something new I want to get to hear
something relatively new I want to get
to and you and I'll look over that
before I go onstage but I don't have a
list of the bits that I'm dropping they
just fall away
I'll take fall you know it there's
something like you say about your
subconscious that just goes I've had
enough of this one and
just gone and then you and then a year
later you think and go oh I used to do
this bit about such-and-such and I just
it just fell away I never did it again
after my special yeah we gotta take a
real quick break here so I can do a
little bit advertising here and I almost
did the radio thing I was think to do
that we're here with Brian Regan like
like people don't listen to these things
wire-to-wire so uh I'm gonna do a little
bit of you know let me read out loud
here everybody and I will be back in a
second all right everybody trunk club
trunk Club get you clothes in a trunk
you [ __ ] trunk club everybody shopping
is awful who has the patience for
crowded stores lay they do or the time
to run I [ __ ] hate computers you know
something every [ __ ] [ __ ]
time I try to do anything in these
[ __ ] you know I got a brand new
[ __ ] computer and somehow it's synced
up to my [ __ ] phone so every time I
had a text message he goes ding ding and
half the time it's behind I already saw
it on my [ __ ] phone I don't I don't
even understand these things on any
level I know what somebody say go to
your settings you figure out how to shut
it off trunk club everybody shopping is
awful who has the patience for crowded
stores or the time to try on 10 pairs of
pants that don't even fit well well why
don't you look at the sizes and pick a
color for Christ's sake you need 10 of
them alright but here's a problem you
still want to look great I want to look
great with trunk club you never have to
set foot in a horrific mall again please
include all of the following points
during your read what do you think I'm
going to skip over stuff why would you
include that sentence you know I'm going
to read it
trunk club takes the hassle man out of
shopping by shipping you a trunk full of
clothes that fit perfectly and make you
look like a million bucks
with all the new fall styles at trunk
club.com slash burr you answer simple
questions about your style preferences
sizes and are assigned an expert stylist
they'll curate clothes from the best
premium brands and you approve of what
you like the hell is this get it out of
here
I just look
and just like that a trunk arrives on
your doorstep filled with hand-picked
clothes there were hand sewn by children
in El Salvador that are perfect for you
try them on keep what you like and
easily return what you don't in that
prepaid trunk this is not a subscription
service so relax you only pay for the
clothes you keep from your trunk no
hidden charges just great clothes get
started today
get started today and trunk club will
style you for free man plus free
shipping both ways you only have to pay
for the clothes you keep to take
advantage go to trunk club calm / / one
last time that's trunk club calm / / for
a trunk filled with clothes you'll love
wearing oh here we go but boot me undies
me undies no more sweaty balls but who
do me undies me undies washing with
concentrated at all and get the [ __ ]
stains out of your crotch but there'll
be no ball sweat cuz they're nice and
dry get yourself a pair of me undies and
your balls will feel like they're velvet
oh yeah alright me undies we all know
how sexy confidence can be and that
confidence comes from being comfortable
but how can you feel comfortable with
your balls it's stuck to the side of
your leg
how can you feel great if your underwear
is wrinkling and riding up the undies
gets it and that's why they've created
the world's most comfortable underwear
we had some of the smartest scientists
with some of the sweatiest balls in the
world to solve their own problem and now
that passing that knowledge onto you for
a daily dose of confidence you wear
underwear every day
that's 365 days a year rain or shine you
need well sometimes you wear two pairs
if you work out right or if you have an
accident you need to be extraordinary
without an insane price tag you need to
be an extraordinary without an insane
price tag we undies understands this and
that's why they've created the world's
most comfortable underwear luxury at
half the retail price you find anywhere
else
when you look good you feel great -
cliche because it's true
me undies understands this and that's
why they design underwear that makes you
look and feel fantastic nope
Motel is pound pronounced model
my undies is the mod elf a fabric that
is is made from mod L a fabric that's
twice as soft as cotton for the life of
me I don't know why they don't have an
accent on which syllable I'm supposed to
I'm supposed to Bob stress model mode al
it's maybe this [ __ ] that evidently
makes you balls nuts what that's twice
as soft it's whatever underwear you're
wearing right now me undies has tons of
colors and styles and the only place to
get matching pairs for men and women
they even release a new design every
month I wear fill in the blank design
parentheses black stripes tie-dye etc
and parentheses plus we all know that
paying for shipping actually guy I wear
the free ones they sent me and you know
what they're great especially when
you're playing hockey
you know enemy if you don't want to go
like you know you don't go commando they
fit nicely underneath your little hockey
pants they're hired Wayne Gretzky warm
in the 90s he got him first that's how
good he was he had he had me on these
back then all right this is getting way
too long
plus we all know that paying for
shipping sucks so me Andy's had to
remove that from the equation all orders
in the US and Canada Canada ship for
free the undies even has a money-back
guarantee if you don't pay for your if
you don't love your first pair you get
to keep it for free well why would you
keep you don't like it you get to throw
it out but no charge to you you
literally have nothing to lose offer
slash call to action to sweeten the deal
the undies is offering you yes
20% off your first order at me undies me
undies me undies dot [ __ ] come my
undies calm / / that's a special offer
just for my listeners and wherever else
they advertise with make sure you go to
me undies comm slash burger to get 20%
off your first order and so that they
know we sent you alright
I love when they say shipping is for
free it's know you've rolled it into the
cost of whatever the [ __ ] you're selling
no Jesus all right Dollar Shave Club
everybody hey can you stop shaving with
an old razor for Christ's sake it's
gross why are you torturing yourself
with a gross old blade week after week
oh that's right probably because you
don't want to shell out 20 bucks for
a pack of new ones will relax calm down
your prayers have been answered
dollarshaveclub.com has the res
revolutionized the way that men shave
with Dollar Shave Club you can shave
with a fresh blade as often as you want
because they deliver a whole sleeve
amazing razors for just a few bucks a
month their razors are so good
millions of guys have joined even the
billion dollar razor corporations are
freaking out because instead of lowering
their bloated prices they're trying to
fool you into I can't read any more men
my eyes I can't see [ __ ]
I like this conspiracy theory even the
building dollar razor corporations are
freaking out but instead of lowering
their bloated prices they're trying to
fool you into milking the same blade for
an entire month and that's gross they
price gouge dust for long enough god
damn right they have never go back to
squeezing weeks and weeks of shaves out
of a disgusting rusty blade joint Dollar
Shave Club and use a fresh blade
whenever you want it feels amazing and
it's a third of the price join the
millions of others who figured out a
smarter way to shave join
dollarshaveclub.com but right now by
going to dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / i love those
guys because that was such a [ __ ]
ripoff I thought about that years ago
Mike why is this little pack of
horseshit blades why is it so much
[ __ ] money you know what I mean but I
didn't have the entrepreneurial spirit
of this guy Christ I could have made a
zillion huh all right let's keep going
here two more everybody stamps calm
everybody get your mailing and shipping
data what getting your mailing and
shipping done can seem like a no-win
situation go to the post office take
going to the post office takes up
valuable time sorry guys I took a
red-eye last night now I'm even worse
than usual leasing a postage meter
expensive with multi-year commitments
and hidden fees luckily I know a better
way what is it you might have asked or
might not have asked stamps.com just
picturing your driving to work - zoned
out not even listening - with stamps
calm by and print official US postage
for any letter or package right from
your desk using your own computer and
printer even get special postage
discounts you can't find it
post-office + stamps calm is more
powerful than a postage meter at just a
fraction of the cost you can save up to
eighty percent compared to the postage
meter and you'll avoid those
time-consuming trips to the post office
I use stamps calm to send out all my
posters whenever I'm going to [ __ ]
myself out on the road you know what I
mean stand out there and have people
with sweaty armpits who are taller than
me rest that hot armpit right on my
shoulder Rose right now use my last name
bur for special offer four week trial
plus $110 bonus offer that includes a
digital scaling up to fifty five dollars
free postage do not wait go to stamps
calm before you do anything else you
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and you type in BER that's
all there is to it
that's stamps comm slash BER no stamps
comm enter BER sorry and finally lastly
but not leastly LegalZoom everybody hey
you shouldn't have to choose a random
lawyer who charges expensive hourly
rates when you need legal help should
you but the legal system is so
complicated what other choice do you
have
when you need help with your business or
want to protect your family well you can
start with Legal Zoom they make it easy
for more than a decade they provided a
way for regular people like you and me
to comfortably navigate the legal system
legal zones not a law firm and that's
how they provide such a great value that
is a weirdest sentence yeah you know
we'll help you with your legal stuff
we're not the legal people but yeah
that's why we're so cheap hey I'll fix
your car I'm not a mechanic but don't
I'll do it for 10 bucks there's got to
be there's got to be an answer to this
in the next paragraph legal zones not a
law firm and that's how they provide
such great value they don't rely on
charging you by the hour instead you'll
get transparent pricing and customer
views so you know exactly what you're
getting upfront well that's a good thing
if you need help within corporations
LLC's trademarks last oh I get it if you
do this through a lawyer they rip you
off they're just they specifically do
this I get it sorry LegalZoom last wills
living trusts and more legal zooms the
smart choice they got the right people
on hand to answer your questions and if
you need legal advice the network their
network of independent attorneys can
provide the straightforward guidance you
need in most states don't let legal
herders hurdles become an excuse go to
legalzoom.com today to start you're
building your own future the right way
to save even more and
birbee you are are in the referral box
that check out that's legalzoom.com
promo code burr and that's it and now
we're going to go back to Brian Regan as
you can tell probably at this point he
can't stand when I compliment him you
know so I'll do it here when he can't
hear it he's one of my favorite comics
of all time and he's he's just the best
and he's the best nicest most humblest
[ __ ] guy ever absolutely love this
guy here's more Brian Regan I
all right and we're back um so I got was
not wanted to tell that story uh you
know um one of the coolest things it was
the first time like I really got to hang
out with you in and meet you I was
playing I was playing the Comedy Works
in Denver right one of the great
all-time rooms and you were playing like
the the United Center the Pepsi Center
or something in Denver this you play
Mike with the Avalanche play her some
red rocks at the Great Divide rocks yeah
well you two shot that video yet again
like I'm unbelievably 8000 seater and
after you did your show you still took
the time to come in and catch my Late
Show at that point I don't think I'd
really for I'd met you a couple of times
but I never really got to hang out with
you right before I went on someone goes
hey just so you know you know Brian
Regan's hanging in the back he came in
and wanted to check out you said and it
was the most ridiculous honor I cannot
leave it then I was thinking like don't
[ __ ] go down into that crouch like he
did 1995 is guys [ __ ] sick he's doing
me will they don't see work how's it
going Yuto you're doing wait a second no
I'd be like yo cut my filthy yeah um and
then we ended up hanging out and you
were so complimentary and nice and and
also something that I loved was you were
like me you were over 40 but hadn't quit
drinking I can't stand people that just
can't you can't [ __ ] handle alcohol I
mean right I should talk right now I'm
going like I shut it down every once in
a while for like 70 75 days and uh by
the time this podcast comes out I'll be
on like day 71 so uh well you know it
was funny in the middle in your set that
night you said that you weren't drinking
you said you know I don't yeah I'm not
drinking now or something like that so I
was taken out man we're not gonna be
able to have a couple cocktails after
the show and then we went out to the bar
afterwards and I said you know I I know
you don't drink gonna go and you're like
oh hold on Butchie boy ya know I was
just like Regan say okay if he's having
a drink I gotta have a drink of Regan
there's no [ __ ] way I'm not doing
this but I just take times off because I
find uh like one of the things that I
cherish about being
stand-up comedian is the free time that
I have to pursue whatever the [ __ ] I
want to do either just sitting on the
couch like right now you know it's a
Saturday when we're taping this I'm
taping three college football game which
I probably won't watch until like Monday
or Tuesday and I just love that I can
just have a Tuesday that if I want to
get up at 9:00 and have an English
muffin and then just watch three college
football games in a row like I'm some
assistant coach watching game film like
I got to break them down for somebody I
just love that I that I can do that but
the dark side of all of that free time
is I can go out and get hammered
whenever I want to and if I don't watch
it I will start drinking again like I
did when I graduated high school with I
just remember like ten days after I
graduated high school my mother just
walked in classic her just really stoic
and right to the point was um your
father and I think you've done enough
celebrating was all she said and that
was her way of saying dude you're a
[ __ ] lush and you can end up in the
gutter celebrating yeah well I mean I
was going out to like like two three
four o'clock in the morning it was so
funny because I always young I would go
on I would be absolutely [ __ ]
hammered and by 8:30 in the morning I
was at my warehouse job unloading trucks
and all I had to do is make it to ten
when the Roach coach came and eat like
us one of those sausages and then it
just sort of leveled me out and I was
fine and somehow I still had a flat
stomach was [ __ ] I didn't realize how
lucky I was back then so that's that's
why I I just go through periods of I'm
just sort of shutting it down
uh to me it's like it's a once every two
month thing you know like I I know the
night that I'm going to be able to get
crazy and I'm careful and I'm not
driving and I don't I know I don't have
anything to do the next day I mean like
it's planned you know when you're
younger you know you just wing it you
know about it but now it's like it's in
my calendar I'm getting wrecked on the
28th
friends you know I was hoping you can
say once every two months you shut it
down could you've been going too hard
like once every two months I drink I'm
like oh god I'm a mess
I'm a mess but I got a I don't know man
like I go on the road with my buddies
you know any those guys
Jason lawhead Joe bartnik just these
great guys that I go to the Rose Bowl
with every year Palmer's E they're part
of that that wave that came probably a
couple waves after my graduating class
and they're all just guys guys cigar
smokers like to go to sporting events
and all of that so it becomes like sort
of a stand-up tour and a little bit of
like a bachelor party kind of vibe you
know - of course the hookers and the
blow and all that type of [ __ ] we don't
we don't know it's pretty mainstream
it's all above the board legal stuff but
you know what happened with the funny
thing is is we get to the point like
none of us you know will be like - we're
not drinking tonight we're not blah blah
and just as something about the
chemistry of all of us really and the
end of the free time that we have that
if we just end up getting absolutely
annihilated like some of the worst
nights of drinking we have is like -
we'll go easy tonight right just shut it
down you know we're gonna hit it hard
last three nights and tonight we do the
show we get in bed we hit the hope we
hit the [ __ ] hotel gym and then we're
on the road sounds good yeah yeah yeah
and then all of a sudden like you know
law heads hosting he'll come off and be
like maybe I just have one heater yeah
and then it's just
and then when laughing as we're doing it
we're laughing just laughing at
ourselves so it's a good game of chicken
because I I have three different golf
weekends a year with brothers and
friends and it's just guy golf weekends
and I don't need a golf and that sounds
awesome
oh man we golf during the day we play
Texas Holdem at night and and you know
I've got this bus you know that can we
use for the golf weekends and it's kind
of cool and sometimes we have a long and
a cool it's [ __ ] awesome yes it's
cool I like golf we get hammered Texas
Hold'em we got a tour bus it's kind of
cool
I got a poker table that was made to fit
in the in the bus so we can play Texas
Holdem while we're rolling so anyway you
know you
in early you get on the bus early
sometimes 7 a.m. you got a long haul to
get to the and there's like 12 guys and
it's like who's going to be the first
one to crack a beer you know and because
everybody's like having coffee and
trying to look like they're sane and
normal you know they have a good thing
of orange juice pretending like we're
normal yeah you know what I mean and
then one guy goes hand me a Budweiser
and then next thing you know 12
Budweiser's are open and everybody just
goes yeah the first guy goes let me get
a Budweiser is this somebody starting a
little early here hey
and in five minutes later they're in you
know the second you just hear it open
just like ah dude I gotta get one of
those the last one I'd last run I did I
did with bartnik and we actually had we
actually went to the hotel gym like
every day this is what I knew I was
drinking too much I had to kind of shut
it down I was getting all [ __ ] bloaty
and [ __ ]
and we had this thing that we did every
day that week after we worked out we
came out of the hotel we went onto the
bus and we had one blood light and we
knew we were just gonna have one Bud
Light because we had a show and you know
we're older guys you know if you have
two drinks you're gonna have to nap for
nine hours right or you'd have to keep
going and you can go for like 12 hours
or you drink two and you're done so we
would have wanting because I knew I was
just having the one I would like savor
it like I would just be like sipping it
like I was you know like when you stole
your dad's first beer and it was like
one of the highlights of the toys I was
a [ __ ] blood light I think I think I
could figure out how to make that in a
bathtub
I can prohibition it was so [ __ ] cold
and delicious just sitting there and
they had you know a little TV there on
the bus and it just sat them we would
always put on like Sports Center or
something and it was uh and then the
hardest thing is when you finished was
not in that next ten minutes to grab the
next one I found it like if I just
forget through that 10 minutes and I
grab the water I started drinking that
like whatever that chemical need of like
a man let's have some more that I would
kind of wear off and I was able to do my
show but uh it's something that uh I had
my brothers and some other friends out
in Las Vegas where I live and
they were on there they're on a golf
weekend I live there and I was able to
join them one night and it was one of
those nights where I said you know I'm I
got a car for us you know and please
call me one of these now yeah love to
for that [ __ ] oh man that would be
fantastic
that's been annoying alkie slowly in for
the drink
when you're flying in oh yeah - Nick so
um I don't play Texas Holdem I don't
golf I'll just be that guy I'll be the
guy see not guilty I just opened that
yeah you'll be our designated first beer
over yeah so we go out and it was my you
know so I got a new I could let loose
you know I didn't have my kids I didn't
have to drive bah bah bah bah so it was
one of those deals where you wake up the
next day and you're like I don't quite
remember the end of the evening I swear
I look on them I shouldn't be telling
the story because uh but I didn't you're
gonna say is gonna be any worse than I
thought
the my shirt I had a button-down shirt
that I had worn the previous night it's
laying on the floor next to me on the
bit on the on the floor next to the bed
I pick it up and there's a tire mark
across the back of it a car tire mark
and I don't I don't know how it got
there I'm like I mean a car couldn't
have run me over
I mean I'm alive I'm in bed I think he
went a little Will Ferrell I think he
took that literally a tire mark and I
had to call my brothers and go how is a
tire mark a car tire mark on the back of
my shirt and they told me that we were
getting in the car and that my foot hit
the curb and I kind of like tripped and
fell on my back underneath the car and
like I might back end it up against the
car tire they see you don't remember us
having to pick you up and put you in a
limo and I'm like damn dude you fell
under underneath the car
yeah not into a car not on a car I fell
under it fell under it without it moving
it's how you got sucked under it's like
it's not even possible yeah that's a
trick shot coming off a curb I don't
know you could do it they said I did
some weird kind
around and then ended up with my back up
against a tire I'm like did you say I
should go home after that I hope those
were your lines yeah it's time for him
to get home I what Joe DeRosa another
one of my great drinking buddies he's
got well he's got a buddy of his back
home you know when you have a beer and a
shot which is one of my favorite ways to
start out you know I mean just sort of
set the tone and his buddy calls it
bingo bango
oh yeah which is the greatest thing ever
to me he just go he came showed up one
time he had a shot and a beer and Joe is
just going like hey when you got going
on there you guys you know bingo bango
just kind of went like with a shot bingo
bang you know hit this one that I hit
that one I would think bang go is the
would be the shot bingos got to be the
beer right well you did a shot first and
then a beer right not in the beer so I
would say bang go bingo
I was hoping I'm trying to rewrite it
out on the road and this guy ordered a
bunch of Irish car bombs okay that's you
drop it's a big thick black stout beer
in a big glass that's not a thickness
what is it in here maybe a Guinness then
you Rob and then you take a shot of
whiskey and you drop the shot glass into
the beer so the whiskey and the beer all
together and then you chug the whole
thing yeah all right
Irish Car Bomb mm-hmm well I got the
name wrong and then the next time I was
in that city all these guys get to it
was Philadelphia and we all went to this
like kind of cool rough Philadelphia bar
yeah and it was this guy who we had done
the Irish car bombs with in his friends
so I'm trying to be like a guy and I
thought it was a mudslide I thought that
which is the you know a chick-chick
drink so I'm trying to fit in and I went
who wants to do some mudslides and my
buddy who was the one who did the Irish
Car Bomb
look at every leg for you the hell are
you doing and I'm like no and and that
now I don't want to back down I'm like
oh you guys don't want to do mudslides
huh like I keep pushing it and they're
all looking
so I go over the bar you know mr. big
Big Shot bartender over here 7/7 and my
slides
set all of us mudslides
except this chick drinks and then next
thing I know we're doing like these
light cream shots oh they all went with
it yeah well because they knew I was a
comedian and they were like well this is
something this guy likes I guess you
know they don't want to like undercut me
and then my friend finally took me aside
no what the hell are you doing here man
and I went this is what we did last time
he goes those are Irish car bombs man
that's like a reoccurring thing with you
it's like you're one of the smartest
guys I know but you're always saying I'm
a [ __ ] and all that type of thing you
just always seemed like every socially
awkward you know what DeRosa did that
when he was in Boston hanging out with
me we we did the show's over at the the
Wilbur and afterwards all my my [ __ ]
knucklehead friends from high school all
my great friends we were all drinking
and and one of my buddies was really
talking to DeRosa they just sort of hit
it off right and then you know he was
any walk told me once point he goes dude
he goes what's up with you but he goes
what's up with you boy I go any much man
he goes he goes she I just asked you
know what do you want for a drinky he
wanted a White Russian he goes dude he
goes dude I'm all set with that guy so
I'm laughing and thinking he's just
breaking his balls so later on the night
after we go to leave and I'm laughing I
go to Rosie no it's hilarious when you
ordered that White Russian my buddy was
breaking your ball balls to me saying he
goes dude I'm done with that guy and and
then Joe just goes is that why you
stopped talking I just he wouldn't talk
to me for the rest of the [ __ ] night
he was dead serious which killed me cuz
that's such like a Boston thing where
like like that's like that rot that
alone imagine Philly's the same way if
you were to order like the wrong like
someone's just like this guy this guy's
cool and then all of a sudden you order
you order something that's just a little
too [ __ ] soft yeah over right you're
dead to me
mudslides much I should get together
with him we'll do some mudslides
somewhere
Russians White Russian chasers
all right bingo bango bongo bingo little
sugar savory sugar salt or something hmm
um all right let me uh let me make sure
that I promote this thing I'm sure this
went by niz yep I knew it for four
minutes already uh but before I get out
of here um I I do want to bring this up
to you we have to talk about the time
when we decided for some reason I'm
gonna say was my idea that we were gonna
do a show together
you know and this is of course was was I
was like not only this guy the funniest
dude ever he also likes to drink I have
to do a weekend with this guy but I knew
that you were playing like these giant
places I think I was doing clubs or
whatever and so I was like I'll open for
I don't give a [ __ ] and then you were
like hey why don't we just do a club you
know the whole excuse was for us to
drink so like why don't we just we'll
just do a club we picked cobbs comedy
club in San Francisco and it was just
like you know for charity but charity so
we figure we won't even make any money
it'll just be an excuse for you and I to
hang to get together and drink and I was
I was going on first you were going on
going on second and uh and that's how I
found out about the st. Jude's charity
which I still donate money to and it
just seemed like such a great idea in
our heads it's such like ads you know
I'm completely filthy you're totally
clean they're gonna get they're gonna
get the total stand-ups white guys
spectrum here and we went up there and I
go on stage and your crowd was looking
at me like who is this angry leprechaun
and I would say on a scale of one to ten
I give my set was about a four and then
you go on stage I'm going on
Regan's gonna at least freak III felt
bad as I got man I kind of bombed in
front of his crowd and everything and
then you go on stage I mean my sister
was there you were killing her and then
all my [ __ ] friends fans are sitting
there looking to you like he's on a
stage for eight minutes he hasn't said
[ __ ] yet yeah I didn't feel like I
killed either I mean I I felt like like
you say I you know I did fine but I
think we both did what I like to do fine
you know what I mean fine is not what we
want but you know it was like for a good
cause
but yeah I think it was like the two
disparate if that's the right word you
know audience make a gap yeah and I
remember afterwards sitting in the bar
and it was sort of like the elephant in
the room that we didn't want both wanted
to dress that we both just sort of did
fine and we were just sort of sitting
here it was ruining our night and
sitting there drinking and then finally
you brought it up you just like like
three three beers he was like so hey
what did you ha
how'd you feel about that was like I
didn't think that went that good and
then we were sort of standing there
little buzz going like yeah dude what
the [ __ ] it was for charity like we said
we didn't be there we almost got like
pissed for a second that we just started
laughing and realized that there was too
big of a gap well it was a noble cause
you know it's weird about that too is uh
I think I forget what and the charity
ended up being American Heart
Association or something like that I
thought we did the st. Jude thing I it
was one of those too but I remember like
answer society something but you know we
contacted my managers office contacted
them that we were going to just donate
all the money and like they don't say
yes right away
which is weird to me they're like well
who are these guys I'm whites right you
know and they want to know a little bit
about us a second where we're giving
money were not asking you for money yeah
and it was like you have to figure out
how to give the money away but what I
think that was because it was probably
the way things are nowadays like if they
get associated with some with somebody
who controversial or whatever like say
Donald Trump the week he said you know I
guess evidently all Mexicans are rapists
he was saying something to that effect
and if he was to donate them money like
the blowback had going to them like god
you're accepting money from a known
racist and then linking we're trying to
cure cancer here you know so anyway yeah
I was a good time he shouldn't have
brought that up uh no it was great man
it was uh it was a blast and I and I
thought we had a great time that night
hanging out so it was cool well I would
like to have done a little bit I'm not
gonna let instead since they're not
still [ __ ] bugs me
I think I probably said that during my
set like dude you understand I want to
[ __ ] be here right now it's like I'm
working for free can you get always you
do can you give it up a little bit we
should do like the opposite extreme like
I should perform in front of your crowd
and then I'll get a 1 out of 10 and you
get a 10 out of 10 and then you can
perform in front of my crowd and maybe
we need we need some of you to feature
to kind of sort of bridge bridge the two
worlds like a david feldman this is
unbelievable
comedian unbelievable joke writer but he
will out of nowhere say [ __ ] on stage
maybe I don't know are you a sports fan
Bryan I like sports but I'm always
reluctant to say I'm a sports fan
because then I immediately get hit with
the question I can't answer I grew up in
Miami I'm a Dolphins fan I like football
and I like golf you know what's a great
thing about you coming out of Florida
Florida has a bad reputation for
comedians like they try to say that a
bunch of hacks come out of there and
then you're always the go-to guy they're
like [ __ ] you they're like Brian Regan
they'd always name three I forget who
the other two are but every city I think
kind of just has three good ones every
state at this point I mean I'm you
there's only the top hundred right
comedians you got 50 states you gotta go
you got two in each state yeah who are
the two from Rhode Island
that's funny everybody's got it I was
trying to steer the conversation towards
sports because I've been defending my
New England Patriots as they've
literally become like the [ __ ]
Antichrist the Antichrist however
however you supposed to say it and just
now at this point like we just after the
nine million thing that we've been
accused of of course just accused
nothing has ever been proven other than
that we cheated for one game in 2007
where we filmed the Jets and a bunch of
people like well then your Super Bowl
championship shouldn't counts like yeah
they should because it wasn't against
the rules for us to be doing what
everybody else was [ __ ] doing we just
ignored them and we cheated against the
Jets that we got ratted out by [ __ ]
mangini
other than that it's just been a bunch
of [ __ ] hearsay I was just hoping
you would either 100% agree with me or
100% disagree with me and we get into an
epic argument about what you oh you're
into golf tee watch tennis at all did
you see Serena lost I saw that she lost
yeah that that was devastating to me
I hate that's why I hate watching tennis
and golf those are the two most brutal
it's all on you it's like doing it's
like doing stand-up on a late-night talk
show if you go out and [ __ ] bomb it's
like you're out there with somebody else
it's just a hundred percent you right
trying to keep your emotions in check
like the first time actually said and I
watched Gulf tournament wire-to-wire
I watched the Masters and I think 2007
it was when the wheels came off with
with Kenny Perry oh and I was watching
that whole thing ruined for this guy
he's never won and he's gonna win his
first major Bubba the guy was like three
[ __ ] holes away the wheel and I saw
his kids go from tears of joy to to
devastation like the guy died and I
later heard that he when he lost he
didn't talk to his family I'm sure he
said a couple of words he just got in
his car and just started driving mmm and
I remember being as a sports fan so
upset that I actually sat and watched
that happen to a fellow human being I
felt horrible I felt like I was looking
at I'm getting an execution watching an
execution almost you know but I mean
there are similarities between that and
what we do you know it's like you have a
horrible set somewhere especially on TV
you know but at least the least you can
blame the crowd on some level you can
stand you know Ellie I'm cannot on TV
but in like a at a comedy club ow [ __ ]
you people you can do something to try
to do something to get least some sort
of I get you're better at that than I am
minor victory any did they just have to
sit there and and and as people are
commentating who don't nearly would
never have the will of the skill to do
what they're doing and just be sitting
there going oh the wheels are just
coming off right now you can
he's he's just visibly upset he's
perspiring they just sitting there just
just giving play-by-play
nobody language you bomb as a comic as
bad as it gets this nobody giving
play-by-play doing that Mystery Science
Theater thing as you're doing it that's
all I'm saying so I I like golf I
actually love tennis but just I like
watching somebody I went to the I was in
France this year and I went to the the
French Open final I was so excited to
see Djokovic win the French and then he
would have won on all four all surfaces
and he would have become part of this
shortlist and he won the first set and
after he won it he looked over at his
coach and he [ __ ] did like that that
Tiger Woods fist pump and I was like aw
man this guy is dialed in he's [ __ ]
dialed in
he lost the next three straight oh man
it was just it was it was great to see
that well Rinka guy went his first one
but that's one thing that is so great
about sports is if you do win a
championship or you do win something you
have that Eureka moment where you can
jump up and down and celebrate and hug
people most jobs don't have yeah now
that line in the sand moment you know
where you can just go oh yeah you know
you go to work 9:00 to 5:00 and you do
what you're supposed to do you don't
have some moment where you're just
jumping up and down on your desk you
know I happy that they should do that
for people every Friday when it's like
459 and they're like well you know do
that one minute nothing the period like
they used to do with the Boston Garden
yeah that would be good I went out down
yeah from ten people got the goggles on
a champagne and all that [ __ ] then you
go home for the weekend like we did it
you know we had a good week at work that
might actually be a morale booster
especially for like some [ __ ] [ __ ]
job I think that would be a great idea
yeah you have your week your weekly
countdown man you sent everybody home in
a good mood
absolutely well do we got we ought to
wrap this thing up I got to do some more
advertising here but it's it's been an
absolute pleasure as a fan of the art of
stand-up comedy to watch is
much as your careers is I've seen into
actually you know when you came down to
the comedy still comment so the comedy
works that that is still and always will
be one of the biggest highlights of my
career and I will definitely be there
what is the date of when you're shooting
it here I got a September 26th a
Saturday 9 o'clock on Eastern Time and I
don't know what time it'll be on all the
other time zones but 9 o'clock Eastern
on Comedy Central
bill you're the best man I've stand-up
comedy special ever first live special
on Comedy Central I think HBO has done
one I think Seinfeld did a live special
in HBO but this is Comedy Central's
first one so that's it's incredible
thank you it's incredible hey listen man
I think you're great I've always loved
your comedy I've always loved your
perspective I love everything yeah I
love your cursing I love your drinking
yes no man um and so I just wanted to
return the compliment man your that's
why we wanted to come down to see you
because you're great well I appreciate
that and next time you are boozing I
don't play Texas Holdem or golf I'll
learn the Texas Hold'em golf I can keep
it on the course hit me up dude
I'll fly in I'll fly and I'll tell my
wife I'm doing a corporate gig just I
just won't show up with any money
afterwards all right please tune in
September 26th at 9 p.m. on Comedy
Central eastern time to watch out their
first live stand-up comedy special with
with one of the greatest comedians of
all time Brian Regan thank you so much
for coming on Brian thank you Bill all
right